Вдень і вночі у Варшаві протести.
Люди зібралися на площі перед будівлею Верховного суду
після масових демонстрацій біля парламенту.
Тут упевнені – польська демократія під загрозою.
Правляча партія "Право і справедливість" захоплює
все більше і більше влади - впевнені демонстранти.
Судова реформа, яку запроваджує нині Варшава,
свідчить про відхід Польщі від ліберальної демократії,
говорять як протестувальники, так і самі судді.
Законопроект передбачає,
що міністр юстиції матиме великий вплив на тих,
хто працюватиме в судах,
на звільнення суддів, на дисциплінарні провадження проти них.
Цей законопроект щодо Верховного суду
є неконституційним.
Опозиція різко виступала проти двох законопроектів
щодо реформи судоустрою, але завдяки
провладній більшості у парламенті,
документи швидко схвалили на минулому тижні і відправили
на підпис президента країни. Якщо президент Анджей Дуда
підпише закони, Верховний суд країни підпорядковуватиметься
міністерству юстиції. Глава мін'юсту
отримає право призначати голів апеляційних
та окружних судівсамостійно, не радячись із
представниками органів правосуддя.
Критики як в Польщі, так і в ЄС заявляють про узурпацію  партією
"Право і справедливість" судової гілки влади.
Але ідеолог партії – Ярослав Качинський -
заявляє, що реформа очистить судову систему від
аморальних колишіх комуністів.
Система, яку ми зараз змінюємо, була системою великих зловживань,
і судова влада, на жаль, була частиною цього. Польська судова система
страждає від краху моральних цінностей. Є багато загальних і
професійних прикладів тому.
Протестувальники не збираються йти з вулиць і площ Варшави.
Вони чекатимуть на рішення президента,
яке має бути ухвалене цього тижня.